good afternoon
i am paulo cravetti i'm an associate
professor of
nephrology at ican school of medicine at
mount sinai new york
and today we are going to talk about
transcriptomic signature specially
result
analysis of the nephron structure in
chronic kidney disease
so um kidney disease is a major
healthcare
problem over 800 millions people
worldwide
have some sort of a kidney
problem and kidney disease is the 11th
leading cause of mortality worldwide
and importantly up to 7
million of people die
because of lack of access to renal
replacement therapy
such as dialysis and transplantation
so the functional unit of the
of the kidney is called the the nephron
so there are about 1 million nephrons
in adult kidneys and they
are composed of one portion that is
called glomerulus
and another one that is called the tubal
in the glomerulus what happens is the
major filtration
of the blood and the the formation of
the initial
urine and then through the the pass
through the through the tubules
um the urine gets concentrated and the
elements
that are important for our organism get
reabsorbed
and some other substances that have to
be eliminated get released by this
fraction of the of the of the nephron
and here is a picture at the electron
microscopy of
one um glomerulus and
it's important to keep in mind that uh
nephrons cannot be regenerated in adult
life so we are born with a determined
number of nephrons and
these nephrons have to be preserved
and kept functioning for all the extent
of our life
importantly if we um focus a little bit
more on the glomerulus
how it works we notice that the the
glomerular filtration barrier that
is what allows the blood to be filtered
the urine to be filtered from the blood
into the urinary space
is formed by three different structure
so one is the podicides which is a
unique
kind of cell that is in the outer space
of the glomerular filtration barrier
and these cells are post-methodic
cells and so they do not proliferate
then on the other sides on the
blood side of the chromoly filtration
barrier
we have endothelial cells that are also
unique because they present
particular fenestration that are
responsible for the first
filtration activity of the glomerular
barrier
and between these two cells we have the
basement membrane here that is a very
thin layer of matrix
that is composed by different um
chains of of collagen that only the
the polycytes can can produce
so we as we said we're born with about a
million nephrons
and over time patients that develop
chronic kidney disease have a
progression
reduction of these nephrons up to a
certain extent
that requires the replacement of the
renal therapy either by dialysis
or by transplant and the the overall
idea
of renal disease progression is that
progressive
loss of functional nephrons leads to the
hypertension
of the remaining one and these leads
initially
represents a compensatory mechanism but
that over on
over time this leads to the loss of
protein
in the urine and progression of the
renal disease
so um it's important to highlight
that homeostatic balance between the
glomerular cells and the glomerular
basement
membrane or gbm which is
vital for the maintenance of the
glomerular ultrastructural integrity and
normal
filtration function is altered during
chronic kidney disease or ckd
and the treatment of ckd has been
historically
focused on slowing its progression by
systemic approaches
that are causing many side effects
and are not specifically targeting the
glomerulus
that as we just saw is the
the main um functional unit
of the of the kidney so uh to
develop new therapeutic approach
approaches it's
important to get a better understanding
of the glomerular biology
and to have a better understanding of
the molecular mechanism
that determine progression progressive
glomerular disease
um it's also important to keep in mind
that not all glomeruli and tubules
are affected in the same way
at the same time even in the same
individual
disease or tissue or gender so
there's really um a variability across
the each each nephron so studying them
all together
like uh like here here's the is the
biopsy of a kidney
that is highlighting the different
structure the different glomeruli and
different
tubules um does not allow to
have enough granularity to understand
the variability
across the different glomeruli and so
by doing so by doing this block analysis
that has been done
until until recently we lose the the
information
that is in crucial to get the molecular
mechanism
important for the renal disease
progression so
there are different techniques to
get more insights about the
about the single cells or single
structure of the glomeruli
here today we are talking about the um
what um is called the nanostring
technology that
allows to have transcriptional
information of the different structure
in uh kidney biopsy and the the way it
works
is by um staining uh the biopsy the
renal biopsy with antibodies that have
only go um um holy ghost that are
conjugated to these antibodies
then the biopsy is um analyzed and we
can
um define the regions of interest
uh where we want to understand the the
gene the transcriptional
phenotype and then once with these
regions of interest are defined
and then the biopsy is undergoes uv
um cleavage of that of the oligos from
the
from the antibodies and then these
oligos get
um amplified and so it will give us the
information about the transcriptional
profile
of each single area that we were
interested in
so by we were interested in using this
technology to better understand
the the renal disease pathophysiology
and so we
started analyzing um a few samples of
patients with normal disease or with a
genetic
renal disease with immune mediated
uh diseases and with a primary renal
disease that is not
genetically um driven so
the first disease we focused on is
alport disease
so this condition is characterized by um
abnormalities in the glomerular basement
membrane
and manifests clinically by the presence
of proteinuria or
protein loss in the urine and um
the the presence of glomerulus carrying
and hearing loss and ocular
manifestation because the same
um collagens that are present
in the in the gbn that are abnormal in
this disease are present also in the
year and in the
and in the eye and here are the genetic
abnormalities that
um that drive this collagen
uh disease and can be in most of the
cases
x-linked so uh associated with with with
sex
uh especially with the in the male sex
but there are also forms that are
autosomal and could be recessive
or autosomal dominant the second disease
we focused on
is membranous nephropathy as you can see
in this representative
um slide membranous nephropathy is
associated with the thickening of the
membrane of the glomerular
um of the glomerular membrane
um in the in the kidney and this is due
to the presence of antibody against
podicide
proteins in most of the cases against
one podocyte antigen that is called
pla2r or phospholipase 2 receptor
and the formation of the immune
complexes in situ
on the on the podocytes leads to
podocyte
injury and then proteinuria protein loss
and progressive renal fat
the third disease we focused on is
called
focal segmental glomerulosclerosis so
the name
means that only some glomeruli so it's
focal
and some sections of the glomeruli so
it's segmental
are interested by the sclerosis so focal
segmental glomerular sclerosis
and so we know that the the
histological re and characteristically
of these diseases as we just
mentioned but the pathophysiology why
this disease is happening is still
unclear
and similar to the other diseases this
this condition is also characterized by
proteinuria
and progressive renal failure so we
decided to use these three diseases
because they are really characteristic
and
of most of the glomerular diseases that
can
happen in the kidney and here
are the the biopsies that we we
characterize
so we took two biopsies of patients with
alcohol disease
two from patients with a focal segmental
rheumatosis
one patients with membranous nephropathy
and one
healthy um kidney that was obtained from
an effect
so the the the renal function that is
measured by serum creatinine
was a little bit variable across across
the different
conditions but as you can see almost in
all these conditions there were some
degree up to a severe level of of
proteinuria
so we took the biopsies of these
patients and then
we defined the regions of interest or on
our eyes that in our case where the
glomeruli
so we picked the glomeruli in each of
these biopsies
and then we took the tubular areas in
each of these biopsies
with the ultimate goal to define the
transcriptional
profile in each of the single areas
of each single biopsy of each single
patient
and so we process this
this data here are the details how we
did this this processing
and the first thing we did was to make
sure that the quality of
our data was good and we
found that the sequencing depth was
consistently high
yielding high confidence counts across
all the samples so
the the procedure work were just fine
and we also verified
that the there was a good dynamic range
across
all the samples in terms of gene
expression
so here you can see the different
diseases
stratified by glomeruli and tubular
areas
and each of this and each of these
little dots represent
one gene that is more or less expressed
and as you can see there are genes that
are blue
and others that are white so it means
that there is a wide range of expression
if this range was more narrow this would
have limited
our our capability to capture
differences across glomeruli and across
patients so this was the first time
we used this technology so we wanted to
make sure that the data made made some
sense so
the first thing that we did was to
compare the expression of genes in the
glomeruli
versus the tubules and we were happy
in noticing that the glomeruli were
expressing
um uniquely um odocide genes that were
not expressed in the tubules
and they were also again the glomeruli
um expressing
genes that were a characteristic of
glomerular endothelial cells and majes
angle cells that can be found
only the glomeruli not in the tubes
we next put together all the tubules and
glomeruli
from the different patients
and again we were reassured in seeing
that in these
principle component analysis that
represent
in a two-dimensional way all the
different um
the um dimension represented by the
expression of each
single gene that the tubals um
cluster different from the glomeruli so
indicating that the
the gene expression profile of the
tubules and the glomeruli was different
as predicted as these are two very
different
regions with two different structure and
different functional
capacities importantly we also noticed
that
in gray you can see the normal tubules
and normal glomeruli from this normal
biopsy
and all the the other ones the other
squares and dots and and triangles
that are um colored are from patients
with diseased kidneys
and the gray and the caudal dots really
well
segregate one from another so indicating
that there is a difference
as predicted between disease and normal
kidneys
we next went more granularly
and we tested each single disease so we
started from
alpha disease the genetic disease and it
was compared between
we against the normal grammar line and
as you can see here in
in the square um the tubal segregates
differently from the tubules of
output patients and the dots against um
was well separated from the dose of the
outboard patients uh interestingly we
also
noticed that in light green and
in in red there um we represented the
two biopsies
one was from a male one from a female
that has slightly different
um genetic abnormalities
and so we were able to notice to
appreciate the difference between the
two biopsies
and within each biopsy each of these
dots represent the different
glomerulus so you can see that
um even though all the glomeruli from
the same biopsy
cluster in the same area there are
different uh differences across
different glomeruli within the same
biopsy
which made this this kind of analysis
very very interesting
and we next um we did this volcano plots
that allow us to
define the differences in the expression
of genes
so on the x-axis we have the fold
change so the more they are on the left
or on the right side
the higher is the difference in the in
the expression between the normal versus
the output glomeruli and on the y-axis
we have the statistical significance so
the ones that we have in the
top left and top right are the genes
that are more
highly more differentially expressed
between
the between normal and and alpha
syndrome
and we were able to identify some genes
that we knew
being differentially expressed and
importantly we found
differences also between the two between
the two patients
um when we compared the two patients the
male and the females
more in in detail we were able to
identify
to to pinpoint the single genes that
differed between between the two between
the two uh
the two patients we did the same thing
for focal segmental chromosclerosis
again here we have the glomeruli of the
fsgs patients and in gray the patients
the the normal glomeruli
that um segregates differently
and here are the the volcano plots
uh all together on the left on the left
in the middle for the
the the male patient and on the right
for the female patient
and if you look at the volcano plot on
the left
uh putting together both biopsies you
can see that the most
highly significantly upregulated gene in
the fsgs patient was the c3
and we were pleased in seeing c3 because
it is one of the complement components
and we had
we have been interested in studying
complement in this in this condition
and indeed is not uncommon to see
complement deposit
in fsgs nor in the plasma of patients
with
fsgs and in patients that have low
c3 so that have a consumption of
complement
there is a lower uh survival of
of the kidney in patients with the fast
gs so
overall suggesting that complement is
important in the pathophysiology of this
disease similar to what this special
and transcriptional analysis was uh
indicating
we arrived to this uh conclusion
through a different path but is is
really
intriguing that um the same path
is uh independently
by this um special transcriptomic
analysis
and to formally uh prove that that
complement is implicated in the
pathophysiology of the disease
um we and others have done some uh mouse
experimental data
in an animal that don't have c3 and as
you can see in green the mice that don't
have c3
have less albuminuria or proteinuria or
the disease severity
than wild-type controls upon exposure to
adremycin that is one of the of the
strategies to induce
fsgs in mice
um we um next move
to our immune mediated disease
membranous nephropathy and here we
also found the pathway and
that we were not really um aware of that
was
upregulated the il4 pathway here you see
in the volcano plot an up regulation of
one of the gene of this pathway
and in the um
and in the expression um
pathway uh again il4
um ranked amongst the top pathway
and when we looked into the literature
we found that
indeed th to cytokines so
cytokines by t cells that release um
that produce il4 were a characteristic
of patients with membranous nephropathy
so again so these these data with the
spatial transcriptomine
were partially confirming the previous
literature
but also pointing at new genes
that in the future we will be interested
in studying
and studying more so the next step
for this um kind of study will be to
um assess the differences not across
biopsies
but across the various glomeruli and
tubules
which was the main initial reason why we
did we use this technology to start with
and as a step further we use the
computational
um so the question is are there a
difference across
cells within a single glomerulus and to
answer this question we use a
computational strategy
to um make a deconvolution of the cells
that are present in each glomeruli
and in each tool that we selected in our
region of
interest so using this computational
algorithm
we were able initially to define
differences
in the cell component composition
between glomeruli and tubals
which was expected but was kind of our
control that this algorithm was working
just fine
and here just by looking at the
composition
um sorry of the different um cells
in the glomerulin tubules we were able
to identify for example
in the glomeruli some cell subsets that
were not really
um expected to be um part of the
glomeruli
and similarly so in the in the tube
and if we just look at the composition
of the different cell subsets in the
glomeruli and
in the tubules we were able to identify
already some
differences across the different um
across the different
biopsies and and this was true
for the glomeruli as well as
for the for the tubals
so the next step here will be
to assess the gene expression profile
not just in each glomeruli but in each
cell subset within
a single glomerulus which is expected to
give
us um important information about the
variability
across a different glomeruli and
understand
whether glomeruli that have um similar
uh histological feature
have a similar transcriptional profile
or vice versa
if um grameoli that look different
have a similar page um transcriptional
um pathways that are activated so that's
will be um we believe um very
important to better understand the
molecular mechanisms
that are responsible for the renal
disease progression
and finally to
together with the transcriptional um
profile
we also tested the protein expression
profile
within the kidney so the same slides
slides actually serial slides were also
stained
for different um markers protein markers
and the the purpose of this staining was
to on one hand um validate
the the transcriptional profile so that
if we saw
upregulated gene we could confirm that
also the protein were upregulated
but was uh the other idea was also
to um define um
to better define the single structure in
the
in the in the kidney based on the the
expression marker
that could allow us to identify
um regions in smaller regions of of
interest and to test their their profile
within these regions
and these are the preliminary data that
we
obtained so far with this um with this
technique
where there are many proteins of these
um
panels that are not really over or
underexpressed but there
are two subsets of proteins that are
expressed highly express or express
um or um or express
or lowly express that will be
informative to better understand um
and integrate the transcriptional
profile data
so um overall to um to conclude and
summarize our data
we observed differences between alport
fsgs
and membranous glomeruli as well as
between glomeruli and tubals within each
disease
we found that not all glomeruli or
tubules are affected in the same way
even within the same kidney and the
spatial profile
can clearly help us understanding such
differences
it also seems that males and females are
often
affected with ckd different differently
and this was clearly observed in our
alport
and fsgs samples this could be
attributed by the
the variability across samples but could
actually be something that is really sex
dependent so understanding their
differences at transcriptional level
and also at the protein level could lead
to more specific and personalized
therapies
so um in conclusion the spatial
profiling of
gene expression and we think is helpful
tool that will allow us to answer some
very important question
about the mechanism of disease
progression in glomerular lckd
such as alport fsgs and membranous
nephropathy
thank you for your attention
i will do some quick editing on the
front and back ends and then
we will get your uh presentation ready
for the event
okay excellent awesome any questions for
me before we
wrap up i think uh i'm good
so on my side what i have to do is just
to give you the numbers of the slide
that i would
not would like not to be included in the
pdf correct
yeah you can do that or you can um edit
your
pdf or your slide deck and remove the
slides that you don't want you can send
me over that side deck and i can use
that
okay that's probably easier okay let's
do so perfect
that's it and you're gonna send me like
the link to the to my presentation and
that's it
yeah i can send you a preview link once
we're done with some editing
okay excellent all righty well we will
talk to you soon have a good rest your
day
bye bye bye